The first we will go ahead and import.
our libraries
we have tensorflow.
we have
Keras so tensorflow
actually want to say from tension flow. We want to import the following
items.
the data sets
the layers
and the models
and
You want to visualize our metrics? So we will import and
visualize the data set.
Some of the data some of the pictures this data
citizens is a set of pictures.
Matt
plot lip dot Pi plot
as PLT
Now for those of you this session, we're able to see that video.
That I referenced.
or
Adam the Adam algorithm
Okay, great.
so
the next thing we want to do is import our data set.
from the data sets object
I will use the method.
load data, so C4 10
C410 dot load data, let
me show you what C4 tenants so database of pictures.
Small pictures and they are all
uniform in size.
Now this method will return.
training images testing images accompanied by
their labels
If these are terms with which you are not familiar, I will explain
them to you in a moment.
So we have
a train images
and the train labels
test images
test labels
Well this downloads. Let me show you the C4 database. This
is it.
Here we go.
It is a data set that contains 60,000 pictures.
That are only 32 by 32.
all color
and all of these 60,000 pictures fought into
one of ten classes.
Here are focuses.
the fundamentals of neural networks, so
Once we covered this.
Example and we understand.
what the
why we
Have this particular architecture our new
electron people will then be able to well build upon what
we know?
And then we can work with other pre-trade models
or even come up with our own models so
we can go to research papers.
and they will make reference to different types
of
neural network layers, but once we
have a foundational understanding we can
create our own architecture and make sense
of
those research papers
So the pictures are these are some of the pictures they're very
small 32 by 32.
Okay. Well, we're gonna train a model
that is that will be able to classify pictures like
so like the ones you're seeing here.
And they all have certain characteristics. So for example the subject.
Of the picture is in the center of the picture like
this car this bird.
this bird
this
these deers
moose
You don't have any of these into Pie by the way.
so
my Elks, there we go.
What do we call the class of such creatures deers whose elk?
I think most are quite large right there. I think that the largest
of
their type
but yeah.
all of these big
pictures have the object running the
center.
So the more all of that we are going to build or
train can only accurately classify
pictures of this nature.
Square
in size
and the subject is clearly right in the center. And of
course it belongs to one of these same classes. So if you go if
you want to predict, let's say
a
I don't know.
A basketball or a
person?
It will not be able to do so.
or what I will do well when we see it's not going to be able to do so
it's going to
Put them into the class that is closest.
Or the class that is most probable.
which will be incorrect anyway, but again, this is
the point here is not to create a
Production level machine learning model, but just to
understand the fundamentals here, okay.
But return here now that the data set has been
downloaded.
Let me it's right now in the
environment. So I don't think it will appear here in the files and folders.
So it's actually they are downloaded into the memory the
temporary storage of the computer.
the instance on Google Cloud
so if I were to type in LS by the
way in call app
you are able to.
Work with two programming languages and of course markdown markdown,
we don't call a program with language if you want to work
with the batch script you put you put in a percent.
And this exclamation mark tells collab that
what follows after the exclamation mark will
be bastard.
So we can use the LS.
Command to list.
The contents of what we have just downloaded.
Or actually the contents of this folder.
Okay.
What we want needed in this example, though.
Let's carry on.
then we have
the images in the form of a tensor
so if you remember by the way you tensorflow is
built on top of numpy
so
data will be for will be stored in the form of a numpy.
Object and if you remember we said that a numpy object as
three attributes
and the data.
So one of those attributes is shape.
And hereby shaping me this shape of the tensor.
so
I want you to imagine.
A tensor to be a collection of matrices. Let
me show you a picture here.
There's a glory that I have created.
in
a Word document
which I will share with you as well.
Let me just because I have the picture in there. Oh Siri.